l'effort à l'heure avec je danse le mia
voici ayama
sûr de lui
bonsoir bienvenue
mais en mettrait remettrait fans alors
nom prénom surnom commençant par toi mon
prénom de naissance philippe et
abdelhakim de conversion ouais c'est
musulmans ouais ouais et le surnom de
cyence et akhenaton akhenaton et toi
eric et keops toi jo ce week-end toi
pascal et imhotep dirait la pub pour le
renault espace
exactement comme un patron l'espace en
préfecture à l'arrière
vous êtes connu aux baumettes non au
beau matin à dire nous mêmes y est allé
non non on n'est pas allé 1 n'a sûrement
des gens qu'on connaît là-bas mais vous
êtes connus ou
surtout dans aurait
des soirées milieu laurent 89 j'ai fait
un premier album s'appelait concept
ainsi ça et qui était un peu l'invention
du rap du sud alors c'est quoi le rap du
sud
ce qu'on connaît c'est vrai reconnaît
massilia sound system on connaît
réglisse maintenant on connait iam on
adore mais si on devait le définir ce
serait quoi alors à boussu c'était
surtout au niveau de la diction de la
prononciation on essayait de garder un
maximum l'accent d'où vous venez mais
après maintenance on s'aperçoit
rencontrant les gens en voyageant dans
la paris en allant dans notre ville qui
a déjà en fait c'est une question de
mentalité
il ya des gens qui sont du nord qui a la
mentalité du sud entre guillemets pour
nous aider jeannie film que la maternité
du nord j'ai des gens qu'on le voit en
général en 99 et la première partie de
madonna à bercy
vous n'êtes plus tard qu'est alain je
tiens à vous le dire quand même les
rôles se sont inversés
moi je crois qu'elle peut faire vous
première partie serait contente de faire
mais elle n'est pas d'accord
cinq minutes de balance comment ça s'est
passé parce qu'il ya quand même 17 mille
personnes s'étaient vis-à-vis des gens
ça s'est pas mal passé par rapport à ce
qu'on nous a donné c'est à dire on
n'avait pas de pratiquement pas de temps
de balancer les ballons sur les
répétitions 20 fr alors on a demandé aux
ingénieurs l'ingénieur a demandé 5000 $
bon et elle est pas venu nous dire une
seule fois bonjour les choristes par
contre sont extrêmement sympa et ça tous
les soirs ça va bien ouais mais avec l
eau que j'essaie de faire en plus les
premières parties puisque les gens est
terrible c'est dire madonna pendant mais
c'est une césarienne dit je t'aime
pâture je sors sur 191 ya eu de la
planète mars la planète mars c'est
marseille c'est vrai que c'est on va en
voir parler c'est exactement ça et en 93
de fameux album ombre et lumière d'où
est tiré le tube je danse le mia c'est
quoi un milliard
c'est assez vaste c'est à dire c'est
certain type de personne qui sait des
personnes très attachante elle ne se
moque pas du tout maintenant connais
beaucoup surtout c'est déjà très
méditerranéen qui ont la chemise ouverte
points qui sortent janin en effet sympa
et qui brille en fait un brushing
calculé au millimètre et tout est bon
chez nous il y en a beaucoup aimé
generation vue de partout 6 mm même ici
même ici même à l'étranger aussi il
roule en quoi le mia en général c'est
les golfs maintenant avancer vers 12 mai
parce que dans le clip ya'll r12 que
j'aime et qui est le super bien qu'ils
aient à mercedes sur la mer ouais si la
leko et demi après c'est toujours une
voiture flambant bat ouais alors
décrivez mois quand même la r12 de vorey
parce que c'est un bonheur cinq ans on
n'a plus beaucoup mais on en a vu
beaucoup à une époque il ya deux types
qui circulait beaucoup qui sera celle de
nos rêves c'est toute blanche avec la
bonne rouge sur le côté oui merci comme
starsky and hutch et ce que vous dites
les couleurs sont avertis mais c'est
pareil tout collant pioneer demain le
nom de le nom avec le nom de la femme à
côté ça ça fait bien c'est déjà avec
plusieurs couleurs un dégradé la côte du
personnel la queue de renard au sinaï à
la bleue avec la bonne de plage avec les
arceaux de sécurité
tourne à 80 km
laurent
c'est la gordini mais maintenant ball
golf gti comment elles sont alors ils
sont préparés sans que ce tome est un
peu quand même non surtout les
way oui c'est ça ouais ça c'est tout les
trucs c'est dur dit l'agent derrière des
fois il ya ceux sur la vie travail à une
espèce de truc des couchers de soleil un
peu des chromos des trucs comme ça c'est
bien ça à wil et surtout je sais pas
comment ça s'appelle calais les pare
soleil avec avec des tigres gore avec
des plages et des soins de ça s'est mis
alors définitive en accord ses
compagnies les plus chers comme ça c'est
clair
il fait quoi le mia comme boulot on
s'est mariés c'est pas dit d'aucuns
y en a le plus à marseille qui est
chauffeur de taxi way lao du barman moi
c'est là où on a vu les photos de guerre
les plus jeunes chauffeurs de bus way
nous ça nous plaît on est un peu mieux
chez de moi d'ailleurs ya d'humain le
tee shirts et quelques semaines le tee
shirt d'un futur d'un groupe de rap
américain vivant il est bien mis à moi
je trouve petit chat est là et là c'est
quoi c'est ça c'est néfertiti ouais
c'est un cadeau sous le bras il ya
toujours des grosses médailles des trucs
comme ça général n'a pas des chaînes
fille née comme ça en général c'est
c'est du costaud qu'il a autour d'un
même point d'attaché du bateau et
je suis pas juif est de taille il boit
quoi enfin pas si ce pastis comment ça
s'appelle le pastis et s'appelle
le jeu ou alors mauresque perroquet tous
ici il ya beaucoup de pastis et pas
beaucoup d'eau clc1 flanc yamaha
le fly like c'est quoi le jure non j'ai
des filles ah ouais c'est mal comment
une équipe donne une cagole
ça peut carrément
combien il y en a plusieurs types aussi
deux salles de quartier qu'on voit dans
notre quartier des fois c'est vraiment
ouvert on habite pratiquement tout ce
centre ville c'est juliette c'est là où
plus personne et parce que marseille
maintenant ils l'ont dit les gens vont
habiter à 20 30 40 km de marseille
maintenant
les gens qui ont peur ouais
non sinon marseille c'est une vie qui
demande qu'à renaître il faut surtout
pas que dès que les jeunes même même les
gens âgés qui sont à notre mémoire à
l'époque à leur époque par exemple ils
sortaient des tables dehors il faisait
les grilladins d'image il savait ce que
c'était se rencontrer nous on a un peu
oublié ça on en serait à peine taper
pour demander le salon voisin maintenant
c'est un challenge et marseille c'est
devenu très occidental par amour avant
et donc donc les filles elles ont quoi
le survêt tacchini saurait tacchini la
panthère quartier qui pendant ou à l'or
sinon grains de classe alors dans les
boîtes c'est les bottines en cuir qui
remonte jusqu'à la mini jupe
en jean délavé tu déchires il qu'est ce
qu'il ya de mieux à marseille alors
qu'est ce qu'il ya de mieux on peut on
peut arriver à vraiment rigolé à dallas
il ya des amendes et des phénomènes
comme on dit et ça c'est magnifique moi
j'ai bon beaucoup de gens ont des
clichés sur le rap il verrait les
rappeurs bras croisés en train de faire
émerger en moi je m'éclate à m'asseoir
voir des vieux qui jouent aux boules à
savané ou jouer aux cartes quoi tout ça
j'ai passé et il y avait des jeunes qui
écoutait durable sur place d'abel de
medan son quartier bon on peut
s'atteindre soit dans une autre vie il
serait là en train de regarder ce qui se
passe dont il avait il y avait un bain
et jouer aux cartes à deux heures du
matin je vois je vous raconterai en fait
c'est quand même basé sur une vraie
acceptation du pays à commencer par
l'accent et puis par les travers du pays
que que vous ne regrettez pas pour pour
devenir français en fait c'est ce à quoi
non on trie l'identité marseillaise
identité culturelle marseillaise à
l'identité française c'est dans la
culture ce qui ce qui émerge en ce
moment c'est un vrai indépendantisme
marseillais par rapport à dire marseille
c'est pas la france
la france est exactement on est tous
solidaires dans la galère c'est comment
ce soir on vous met le feu ce soir vous
mais ce forum
est inconnu qui ça nous ça nous fait mal
parce que c'était le nôtre le fait c'est
une expression marseillaise c'est le
stade aux normes qu'il a repris 5 ont
atteint les autres tous les autres
l'instar de crise au sommet le feu s'est
fait drôle encore il faut s'asseoir ne
faut perdre son charme sa personne
charme
alors maintenant je vais vous
dématérialisée voulez vous retrouver où
vous mettez les portes et où
on a plein sur l'âge à marseille j moi
j'aimerais bien retourner bon d'accord
mais tu vas y retourner attention où
vous mettez bien comme ça au fermer les
yeux et gaf 1 les autres sites aux
baumettes
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus